>> If I say the cat purrs or
this cat hunts mice, it's
perfectly reasonable to also say the
kitty purrs or this kitty hunts mice.
The context gives you a strong
idea that those words are similar.
You have to be catlike to purr and
hunt mice.
So, let's learn to
predict a word's context.
The hope is that a model that's good at
predicting a word's context will have to
treat cat and kitty similarly, and
will tend to bring them closer together.
The beauty of this approach is that you
don't have to worry about what the words
actually mean, giving further meaning
directly by the company they keep.
There are many way to use this idea that
similar words occur in similar contexts.
In our case, we're going to use
it to map words to small vectors
called embeddings which are going
to be close to each other
when words have similar meanings,
and far apart when they don't.
Embedding solves of
the sparsity problem.
Once you have embedded your word into
this small vector, now you have a word
representation where all the catlike
things like cats, kitties, kittens,
pets, lions, are all represented
by vectors that are very similar.
Your model no longer has
to learn new things for
every way there is to talk about a cat.
It can generalize from this
particular pattern of catlike things.